[Music]
over three years ago disney decided to
cut ties with its renowned director
james gunn after some controversial
tweets in retrospect it turned out that
many responsible people were disregarded
in this decision and above all it became
apparent that the guardians of the
galaxy franchise would be better off
with james gunn after all meanwhile gunn
joined rival dc and filmed the suicide
squad while disney tried hard to bring
gun back for guardians of the galaxy vol
3. since then quite a bit has happened
for despite the pandemic a great deal of
work has been done on the third part of
the past few months a few days ago james
gunn finally revealed on twitter that
filming of guardians of the galaxy 3 had
begun appropriately gun published a
small emotional message and a photo of
the main cast in addition to the
director you can see chris pratt palm
clementine zoe saldanas dave bautista
karen gillian sean gunn as well as
chukwudi iwuji who you know from guns
peacemaker series
besides there is one newcomer who is not
visible in the picture and that is will
polter the 20 year old will play the
role of adam warlock in the upcoming
part as has been known since recently we
hope for a trouble-free shooting and are
already looking forward to guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 which is scheduled for
release on may 5th 2023
bad news for star wars fans as reported
by the hollywood reporter those
responsible for star wars rogue squadron
will not be able to meet the production
schedule the main reason is director
patty jenkins who has yet to complete
her two major projects cleopatra and
wonder woman 3 first as if that were not
enough she is also simultaneously
working on a wonder woman spin-off about
the amazons originally the plan was to
let the filming of rogue squadron take
place between the shooting of wonder
woman 3 and cleopatra in the meantime
however they have realized that the time
window for star wars movie is far too
tight making the postponement the only
reasonable thing to do the original
release date of december 22nd 2023 is
still to remain important however rumor
has it that another star wars movie will
be released on this date instead this is
supposed to be the film by director jd
dillard and screenwriter matt owens
which was officially announced in early
2020. at least that's what some fans are
speculating which includes ruling out a
project by ryan johnson on that day due
to his involvement with the knives out
sequel dillard on the other hand has
practically completed his devotion
project and would in theory have time to
realize a star wars film soon the plot
could then take place in the age of the
high republic for example similar to the
upcoming series the acolyte of course it
should be noted that this is still pure
speculation since it's neither certain
which star wars film will take the place
of rogue squadron know what its plot
might look like
the play harry potter and the cursed
child has been a well-known name to many
fans for quite some time the idea of the
play comes from jk rowling jack thorne
and john tiffany and continues the story
of harry potter 19 years after the epic
battle against voldemort harry now works
in the magical law enforcement at the
ministry of magic and is a proud family
man his youngest child albus everest
name of course after the two famous
wizards suffers from being in the
spotlight all the time and is looking
for a way out of his father's shadow in
an interview with variety director chris
columbus talked about his desires to
bring the play to the big screen as well
he said that the actors of harry iran
and hermione are at the ideal age to
star in the cursed child he's referring
of course to daniel radcliffe rupert
grant and emma watson all of whom are in
their early 30s and that's only a few
years younger than their respective
characters in the story the idea of a
movie adaption certainly has its appeal
but there is one major problem with it
the play relies on time travel to
earlier events two characters who appear
in flashbacks are for example snape and
mcgonagall unfortunately alan rickman
has already passed away in 2016 and
maggie smith is 86 years old therefore
the question arises as to how an
appearance in the movie could be made
especially with snape they are likely to
scare off the entire fan base with both
a recasting or an insertion via modern
film technology what do you think of the
idea of a film adoption and what are
your thoughts on how it could be done
feel free to tell us in the comments
last thursday paramount announced that
two high quality films have been
significantly pushed back one of them is
transformers rise of the beasts the now
seventh part is directed by stephen
kippel jr and is set in brooklyn during
the 1990s unfortunately fans will now
have to wait much longer because as
those in charge have communicated rise
of the beast will no longer be released
in june 2022 but on june 9th 2023 the
same is true for the second paramount
film star track which is now scheduled
for release on december 22nd 2023 not
much is known yet in terms of content
and other than director matt jackman and
screenwriters josh friedman and cameron
squires no big names have been revealed
paramount's maneuver regarding the
postponement of star trek could actually
be related to disney's rescheduling of
rogue squadron because apparently those
involved are speculating that this time
frame is now free and thus they won't
have to release in direct competition
with a star wars movie on the theatrical
market regardless fans of both star trek
and transformers will have to remain
patient
vin diesel and dwayne johnson have had a
somewhat troubled past the two have
clashed on set more than once and
eventually the dispute even resulted in
the splitting of johnson's character
luke hopps into a spin-off of his own
additionally johnson announced he would
in no way return for the 10th fast and
furious installment on instagram diesel
now posted a picture of the two of them
with a fairly long text aimed at getting
johnson to reconsider his decision among
other things this talk of diesel's
children and their uncle dwayne sending
each other well wishes every holiday
moreover there is no other actor who
would be suitable for the role of lugops
according to diesel's own tone then
there are the reactions of the fans to
the post many rather johnson should pull
himself together one more time
especially for paul walker and the fast
and furious family one thing for sure is
that dwayne johnson is the highest paid
actor in the world and has no need
whatsoever to be starring in fast and
furious 10. diesel's attempts to get
johnson to return in this manner are
also kind of sneaky and only served to
turn fast and furious fans against
johnson should he decline the offer
there's still some time until the
release of fast and furious 10 on april
7 2023 but we still do not expect
johnson to be part of this film
the manga series one piece which has
been running since 1997 is one of the
most successful of its kind for some
time now it has been known that netflix
wants to tie in with the franchise's
great success by creating its own live
action series the official twitter
account provided us with a first
impression of the actors in accuracy
last tuesday in addition individual
portraits of the cast were published we
can see enyaki godoy who will play the
nation pirate king monkey d luffy he is
joined by mckenyu as swordsman rorona
zorro emily raddez navigator nami jacob
gibson as craftsman and sniper uzop and
tas skylar as well dressed chef zunji
expectations couldn't be higher given
the enormous popularity of one piece but
the first look at the cast seems
promising at least we can only hope that
this series doesn't follow in the
footsteps of the netflix movie death
note which was highly criticized by the
fan community unfortunately a release
date for the 10 episode series revolving
around the straw hat pirates is not yet
known
up to now fans of the science fiction
universe gundam have had to be satisfied
with only a little information about the
plan live action film adaption although
it is assumed that the adaption from
legendary will be very similar to the
original series more details are still
being kept under wraps at least there is
a first promising photo to admire the
concept art shows one of the many robots
that are controlled by humans and play
major role in this science fiction story
in the tv series humanity has long since
left for outer space where various
colonies have been formed eventually war
breaks out with the earth the initial
image wets the appetite for more even
though it's not entirely clear when
gundam will be released in any case it
has been decided that the movie will not
be shown in theaters it will only be
available via video on demand
and that's it for the latest news fans
of terrific creatures should definitely
not miss our latest original on jurassic
world dominion you can also find the
most recent clip for ghostbusters
afterlife and the first trailer for the
toy story spin-off light year on our
channel
[Music]
foreign